What happens to This Perfect Day by Ira Levin
when it is placed into SCP-914?
One flash drive containing a text file of
This Perfect Day by Ira Levin was placed into
the Clockworks on the setting "Very Fine."
The output produced was:
One flash drive containing a single .jar executable.
Every attempt made to decompile the file was
met with failure and a notice of "technical
difficulty."
When executed, a log file was created depicting
"The Most Effective Way of Life" for everyone
in a 200 meter radius, followed by ten genome
sequences with five for each gender.
Intern Beauvillier voted, “Interesting,
to say the least.
Although I don't see myself becoming a plumber
anytime soon.”